sa collègue c'est un sujet qui c'est un
dossier qui prend du temps mais je
comprends un petit peu la réserve et la
réalité sur le terrain qu'ils puissent
en prendre
je n'avais jamais vu dans un exercice
récente de ma vie auquel je me suis dit
je vais au thème de train à grande
vitesse entraîne autant de trains à très
grande vitesse et même au temps
d'autoroute que dans cette portion de
france dont nous parlons si longuement
ce soir et pourtant je j'ai rarement eu
le sentiment d'avoir une perte de vie
d'avoir une disparition de tissu
économique industriel et je le disais de
la vie tout court qui qui prenait aux
tripes et qui promet au coeur on parle
souvent on dit de plus en plus souvent
maintenant il faut écouter les citoyens
moi je vous assure que dans cette
affaire-là et je ne connais pas cette
région comme la connaissent tous mes
amis qui sont ici présents et que si on
les écoute et le problème serait vite
tranché je crois que je n'ai pas trouvé
qui soit opposé à ce projet dont j'avais
pourtant entendu parler depuis plusieurs
années déjà j'avais le privilège de
faire partie de la commission nationale
du débat public
je ne sais pas qui est ce qui est
aujourd'hui comme des buts et c'est une
très belle commission et nous en avions
déjà beaucoup parler mais que ce soit
les marcheurs qui était le long des
canaux que ce soit ceux qui étaient sur
les péniches ceux qui étaient dans les
usines environnantes ceux qui étaient au
chômage
ceux qui étaient dans les villes ce qui
était dans les campagnes
tous souhaitaient de toute leur force
qu'on réalise ses 5 km qui allait
permettre la liaison avec les 20000 km
de canaux de hollande de belgique
d'allemagne jusqu'au danube comme hulu
le dixième mon cher collègue tout à
l'heure
et j'ai été étonné de voir à quel point
ce dossier était connu de toutes ces
deux touches parce qu'ils avaient aussi
la mémoire et qu'ils avaient le sens de
l'histoire qu'il se souvenait qu'il y
avait 80 à 90 européenne toute cette
région
servez tous les jours paris avec la
houle qui lui permettait de se chauffer
la houille qui lui permettait est de
devenir la grande capitale qu'elle est
devenue et il aspirait à retrouver cette
histoire intime qui a été tellement
tranquille par les tragédies et il
pensait que justement ce canal avec de
l'eau avec de l'eau était ce qu'il
pouvait y avoir de plus naturel bref je
ne chercherai pas à convaincre ce que je
n'arriverais pas convaincu je voudrais
dire cependant une chose c'est que j'ai
le sentiment monsieur le président qu'à
force de ne rien réaliser un jour
viendra où soit tout va s'arrêter
donc c'est possible à ce moment là
effectivement on aura peut-être par les
pourriels
je ne fais pas partie de ceux qui le
souhaitent mais si ce n'est pas le cas
notre pays va se trouver dans une telle
situation de thrombose qu'il faudra tout
faire d'un seul coup parce que qu'on
m'explique comment on va trouver une
solution à ces muraille d'acier qui
traversent notre site notre pays
maintenant est-ouest aussi on le voit
sans que nous puissions y tuer l'homme
d'une solution pourquoi parce que bien
des fois nous faisons semblant d'être
d'accord alors que nous ne le sommes pas
bien des fois nous faisons semblant de
vouloir les à lavaré d'avoir l'argent
nous n'avons pas moi je pense que nous
devrions reprendre des investissements
parce que nous sommes dans un pays qui
souffre et un pays dit il sans souffrir
c'est aussi un pays qui investit
moi j'ai pu rembourser mes petites
dettes quand j'étais jeune aux cris de
recall lorsque j'ai gagné un peu
d'argent pour rembourser mes petites des
annuités
or quand on ne produit plus et quand on
réalise plus il ya peu de chances pour
qu'on s'en sorte et en fait je pense
qu'une des solutions sera un jour je ne
sais pas quelle sera la situation des
vous pas ce moment là puisque nous avons
la chance rare ce pays bordé
red océan de faire la grande relation
l'agent de liaison des verts depuis
rotterdam jusqu'à ville va aux
pourquoi pas marseille par le vers le
sepa gibraltar à ce moment-là nous
enlèverons 70 80 % du fret qui traverse
tous les jours notre territoire et qui
n'a rien à y faire et nos enfants
n'auraient plus peur de porter les leurs
à l'intérieur des voitures dans 15 ans
d'ici je remercie